president Trump confirmed minutes ago
he's made his choice to be Attorney
General and US ambassador to the United
Nations the president says he will
nominate former Attorney General William
Bar to replace Jeff Sessions and Chief
State Department spokeswoman Heather
Nauert to replace ambassador nikki Haley
at the UN major Garrett is at the White
House major what do we know about bar
well let's talk about Bar first he was
George Herbert Walker Bush is Attorney
General for just under two years and in
every way an establishment fit pic for
this president who doesn't often do that
and this reflects an urge by this White
House to have someone who would have a
less difficult time winning Senate
confirmation because William Barr served
as George Herbert Walker Bush is
Attorney General and is not viewed as a
trump loyalist the White House assumes
he will have an easier confirmation
battle one thing I can tell you John is
there were some opponents of this
nomination inside and outside the White
House who believed he didn't have a firm
personal relationship with the president
and may not support all of his agenda
items on civil rights and immigration so
that's gonna be an issue internally but
William Bar will be the president's
nominee asked for Heather Nauert she
spokeswoman at State Department former
Fox News News presenter not a whole lot
of foreign policy experience the big
question will she have a significant
voice within the Trump inner circle on
national security and foreign policy as
nikki Haley did John back to you two
really fascinating pics thank you so
much major